Yong: Hi, good,
hello everybody.
My name is Kuan Yong.
I'm the product manager
for the YouTube APIs.
So, you know, whether you've
been using the APIs
for some time now, or if you're
relatively new to the APIs,
my hope is that you guys will
come away from this presentation
you know, with some cool ideas
for your next mashup,
or at least a richer and better
understanding
of what you can and cannot do
with the YouTube APIs.
Now, um...
Forgot what I
was gonna say.
But, the, the APIs--
though, as Vic mentioned
in the keynote this--
this morning
that, the,
the Google data APIs
have exceeded over four billion
requests a day.
And that's not surprising.
The YouTube APIs alone
account for hundreds of millions
of those requests per day.
So we have
a huge community.
Now, as developers,
you know what,
when we're writing apps,
we tend to just go straight
for the API documentation.
You know,
meeting the terms of service
unfortunately for many of us
comes as an afterthought.
But if you guys
haven't already read
our terms of service,
I think you guys are in
for a real treat.
Now, unlike some
of the APIs
that, that you may
have used in the past,
you know, from Google,
or from a different web company,
the YouTube APIs are,
by default,
cleared for commercial use,
which means, if you're
developing an app,
and if you want to sell
the app,
make money
from the app,
you can do so, you know,
without coming to YouTube
and asking us
for permission,
or doing some kind
of a deal with us.
And this is not true
for many of the other APIs.
And we think this is
one of the reasons
why the--our APIs
have grown so big
and grown so popular.
But, you know, with all,
all this power,
and all
this flexibility,
that we're giving to developers,
like yourselves,
you know there comes, you know,
certain responsibilities.
There's a bunch of things
that we do not want
our developers to be doing.
So, you know,
let me start my talk
by going over what some
of these main issues are.
So any guesses from the audience
what's gonna come up
on the next
couple of slides?
You know, based on your own
personal experience
about developer relations
teams, um, groups.
Anyone--
any guesses?
Well, let's start with
a pretty obvious one:
Just trying to access
our video streams directly.
Now the vast majority
of the content on YouTube
are not DRM protected.
So, you know,
it's possible
and, quite frankly,
not too difficult
to rip out streams.
But just because
you can do that,
doesn't mean
that you should.
Our terms of service
clearly prohibits
using or performing
any of the YouTube videos
except through
an authorized player.
Now, if you're just
developing a web app,
this usually means
using a Flash-embedded player.
Pretty straightforward.
But what if you're trying
to develop an app
for non-Flash environments.
You know,
if you're developing
a mobile app.
Well, the, the good news is,
you know,
on some of the
newer mobile phones,
there's already a built-in
YouTube client player,
and, really, what your app
needs to do
is to figure out
how to delegate playback
to this
external player.
And we know that this is not
always possible in all phones,
but, on the iPhone,
for example,
it is quite possible to write
a native app in such a way
that, that the user is taken
to the YouTube player
to watch a video,
and once they're done
watching the video,
they're automatically taken back
to the app where they left off.
So the whole experience
is actually quite nice,
and, um, seamless.
But what about television set,
uh, boxes?
You know,
what are your options there?
And unfortunately,
our terms of service
do not allow you
to develop an app
that's intended for use
on television displays.
So really
you're gonna have to look
for, uh, for
a different technology provider
if that's indeed
your use case.
But, the, constraining yourself
to the Flash players
necessarily mean
that you can't do anything cool.
Obviously, we disagree,
and recently we came across
this really cool mashup
that I'm quite excited
to show you guys.
Unfortunately, the site
is no longer up
because the campaign
is over,
but we have access to, like,
a password-protected version
of this site that I can use
to show you guys.
So this is--this is--
this was done
by a creative agency
in Japan
to promote an aquarium in,
I think it was Okinawa,
um, in Japan.
And, and what they've done
is taken the thumbnails,
which are available through
the YouTube APIs
and mapped them
on a vertices
of a--of a
3-D Whale Shark.
And the 3-D model itself
was created in
Google SketchUp.
So let's see what, the, uh,
end result looks like.
Some of you guys
may have seen this.
Uh, when it was up.
I think it was Tweeted and
blogged about quite a bit
just because it's, like,
oh, so cool.
And it's actually better
with the sound on,
but we're not gonna
use sound here.
So let's give this site
a couple moments to load.
And it should come up
any second now.
There you go.
So this is all done
in Flash.
Very cool, you know,
lots of thumbnails,
all from
the YouTube APIs.
And when you click on
any one of these thumbnails,
the Chromeless player,
which is again,
um, one of our
authorized players,
pops up,
and you play the video
in place.
And, you know, this is
a really cool way to browse,
you know, what looks like to be
a pretty vast collection
of, of videos that the aquarium
has uploaded to YouTube.
So really cool--
the site's not up.
Hopefully, we can get
a screen cap of this
posted somewhere so that
you guys can take a look at it.
All right, second thing
I want to talk about,
just, kind how you name
your product
or feature that uses
a YouTube APIs.
Unfortunately, you,
whoops--
You can't say, you know,
YouTube XYZ.
That's the naming convention
that we've reserved
for our own features.
And if you start doing that,
then users
are gonna get confused
as to who built this.
Was it YouTube?
Was it a community?
So you can't do this.
In some cases,
you can say XYZ for YouTube,
but we discourage this because
you really should be thinking
about building a video app
and not like
a YouTube app,
which is why
we encourage you guys
to just call your product
whatever you want,
and use the Powered by YouTube
branding logo
to indicate to your users
that there is
a YouTube integration as part of
your cool mashup.
Third thing, and this happens
so often it's embarrassing,
you know, just resist
the temptation to monetize
every spare pixel on your
web page with AdSense ads.
This is a terrible
user experience.
I'm sure you guys
already know this,
and not only that,
in most cases,
putting an ad next to a YouTube
video on the same page--
it's against
our terms of service.
And I'll actually go into
the subtleties later on
in this presentation,
but for now, you know,
this is a bad idea.
Also the AdSense
program policies state
that you can't use AdSense ads
in a way that violate
another Google products
program policies.
So you're actually violating
two sets of clauses here.
And it just is a bad idea.
So don't do this.
So while we're on the topic
of, uh, monetization,
one of the things that
you guys may want to think about
is, you know, is there ways
for you to monetize your work
that don't involve
running ads?
You know,
before there was the Internet,
if you wanted to use
a piece of software,
you expect
to pay for it,
you know,
what a novel idea.
And happily,
some of these business models
are starting to reemerge,
you know, especially
in the mobile world.
So if you're writing
an Android ad,
or you're developing
an iPhone app,
if you can sell the app
and make money from day one
by putting the app
on the Android Marketplace,
on the iTunes app store.
So a really clean and easy
way to make money.
If your app is a little more
complicated than that,
you know, you might want to
think about segmenting your app
into a free version
and a premium version.
The free version would be
available to everybody.
The premium version would have
some advanced features,
which may include something
that's YouTube related.
So use YouTube as a way
to upsell your users
from the free version
to the premium version.
And we do this ourselves
with Google Earth.
The free version's
available to anybody.
The Pro version contains
a moviemaker, um, tool,
and part of that tool is
the ability to upload your video
directly to YouTube
once it's done.
So again, the YouTube portion
is not the main reason
why users are paying
for the premium version,
but it's one of
the many reasons
that you use to--
for the upsell.
But you may, say,
you know,
I'm a Web 2.0 guy.
I'm in the business
of creating websites.
Can't really charge people
to come to my websites.
So, you know,
what are my options?
And if this is
the situation that you're in,
yeah, I would think about
the different use cases--
the different parts
of the user interaction--
and then identify
the opportunities
in, uh, each portion.
So there's the
video playback experience.
This is...
the most obvious one.
You tend to overly fixate
on it,
in my opinion,
but unfortunately it presents
the fewest opportunities.
You might want to think about
content creation.
You know, allowing users
to upload videos to YouTube
in interesting,
unusual ways.
Or, you know, content discovery
and organization.
YouTube is designed
for the masses.
Is there anything you can do
to better address
specific niche
interests,
or, you know, communities.
So, you know, basically
your ability to monetize
each part
of the user experience
is roughly proportional
to the amount of value
that you're adding
to the user experience.
Video playback, you know, you're
not really doing something
that a user can't already do
on youtube.com.
So you're not
adding a whole lot of value
by slapping on
an embed on your web page.
But if you're creating
this whole new tool
to create videos,
or this whole new tool
to discover videos,
you're giving users
a way to do something
that they can't before.
You're adding
a lot of value,
and therefore you have
a lot more flexibility
in figuring out
how you want to advertise
against
that experience.
So let me call your attention
to this one specific,
and probably
quite famous, clause
in our
terms of service.
It says that you can't,
you know, sell an ad on the page
that contains
a YouTube video
unless there's already
something else on the page
that warrants
that sale.
And one easy way
to think about this is
if you take the video
out of your web page,
one, are users still gonna
want to go to that web page?
And, two, is there
substantial content
left on the page
that you will want to sell an ad
against that page.
And unfortunately,
there's not a lot of cases
where the answers
are yes and yes.
The classic video
watch page--
the user clicks on
the video result,
watches the video--
that page clearly out of bounds.
But, you know,
there may be cases
where there's a blog article--
it's pretty long, you talk about
a whole bunch of things,
part of that article,
you're referencing
a YouTube video, you have
the clip in place.
If you take that video out
of the article,
yeah, maybe the article is gonna
be a little less interesting,
but users may still want to come
to your page.
Users may still want to read
an article.
So, in that,
so it's justified.
But again,
these cases tend to be
quite, um, rare.
But if you do
find yourself in a situation
where you can actually
sell an ad against
a page with
substantial video content
from YouTube,
we highly encourage
using this feature
in AdSense
if you're using AdSense
to basically screen out
that page,
that part of the page,
containing YouTube
video metadata
from the AdSense crawler.
So you're not
targeting ads
to anything
that's YouTube specific.
This is actually documented
in the AdSense help centers.
So if you guys find yourself
in this situation,
you can
look this up.
It's just an easy pair
of HTML tags,
and you can add
to your page.
So let's talk
about content creation,
which we think
is a lot more interesting.
just because in YouTube
it's all about
users
sharing videos
you know, every minute,
20 hours of videos
are being uploaded
to YouTube.
You know,
it's this amazing community.
And video creation tools
tend to be quite involved
in the sense that
you draw the user in.
It's, uh,
it's a captive audience.
There is quite a bit
of engagement involved
in creating a video.
So, you know,
think about how you can really
monetize and capitalize
on that part
of the user experience.
So one example we like
is Animoto.
If you guys
don't already know,
Animoto--it's a pretty cool
website.
You can upload
photos,
and they use
some really fancy algorithms
to turn those static photos into
fully animated music videos
with all sorts
of special effects.
Now, the process of
turning these photos
into something
that's moving
and engaging
takes time.
And while the user is waiting
for the video to process,
they display what we think
is advertising
on the page,
where, you know, hey,
you know, you're waiting
for us to process
your video,
why not check out this trailer
at the same time.
So again, you know,
captive audience
that you can monetize.
And then content organization
and discovery.
So again,
as I said before,
YouTube is built
for the masses,
to satisfy
as many needs as possible,
but you may be aware
of specific communities
that could benefit from perhaps
an editorial curation of videos.
So, oops, um, one example
is golftuts.com.
What the developer has done
on this site
is manually select
a bunch of videos from YouTube
that he thought, uh,
could be interesting
to anybody
who's learning golf.
And he created a really nice
website experience around it.
So let's take a look.
Let's see.
Here we go.
So much
of this website
is actually monetized
but he--I mean, he's not
monetizing this site right now.
But, for example,
this browse page
with all these
thumbnails and videos,
this page right here--
you know, you can monetize
using your standard
favorite web ads.
But, of course,
the video play page itself
is, um,
out of bounds to advertising.
So that's, um,
creation of videos.
If you don't want to be
in the business
of deciding what your user
should be watching,
you know,
you could think about a site
that encourages
community-driven efforts
to pool together
contents of videos.
So, uh, an example here
would be totll.com.
I think the creator
of that site's here.
Hello, nice to meet you
in person at last.
Cool site, by the way.
That's totll.com.
It's a great site where
parents can submit
YouTube videos that they think
other parents
might enjoy watching
with their young children.
And, you know,
all the content on the site
is community-driven,
but it serves, you know,
a niche need,
and, you know,
we would like to see more
of such mashups
for other communities
on the Internet.
There's so many
videos on YouTube.
It's hard to--
It's hard to find stuff
if you have
a really specific,
narrow focus.
So perhaps, you know,
you as the developer can come in
and do something
really interesting there.
So that's a whole, you know,
discovery part.
And then there's
the browsing of search results.
You know, search results
don't always have to be
a thumbnail next to
some metadata.
That's how
YouTube does it.
It doesn't mean it's
how everybody should do it.
There's other ways
to present video results.
You may have used
Claurus, I think,
which creates this open GL
3-D visual, uh, experience
of thumbnails
in moving 3-D space.
Or, um,
Dipity's Time Tube
is also interesting
in that
it takes
a search term
and does a bunch of queries
to YouTube
in the back end,
and presents the results on
this very beautiful timeline
that you can browse
quite easily.
I've searched for
Obama here.
The search
takes a while,
so I just kind of
pre-populated the search box.
And you can kind of
browse videos
on a timeline.
When you find
something interesting,
you can watch--
double click--
and then there it is:
that standard
YouTube Flash player.
It's really quite cool.
And what makes this site
even more cool
is that even though it looks
and feels like a Flash app,
it really isn't.
It's all done
in HTML and Java script.
So pretty awesome.
All right, now that I still have
your attention,
let me just use
the rest of the presentation
to just kind of go over
some of the issues
that we see developers
run into pretty often,
and provide
some recommendations
on how to deal with
these specific issues.
So, getting
video metadata
and how fresh that
video metadata is.
I get a lot of questions
on that.
And it's--
can be a bit confusing,
because there is
more than one way
to get metadata
from YouTube.
There is the low latency,
high QPS way
for use cases
where metadata freshness
isn't your
number one priority.
You just wanna show
metadata.
So search results,
video description, title,
and [indistinct] result,
or you're building
this site
where the user can paste in
a YouTube URL.
You want to go
to a server,
grab the metadata
for that URL, video ID,
and then create an embed
with the title and so on.
So for these, sort of,
very frequent operations,
you can go to
the videos feed
to grab metadata.
This feed is
very highly cached.
Um, the quota's set
pretty high
so, you know,
you guys can go crazy.
But it's not suitable
for content management purposes.
If you need the absolutely
freshest possible metadata,
there is a different feed
that you have to use,
and that's
the authenticated uploads feed.
And for that
you actually get
the freshest possible
metadata you can get
from the system.
And what it's
really good for
is updating video metadata
on YouTube.
So you want to pull down
the freshest copy
of the metadata,
update it,
and then put it back
on YouTube's server.
It's a pretty expensive
read operation
for us to support,
and for that reason
the quota is set pretty low.
But for most, you know,
ordinary use cases,
you shouldn't run into
any issues.
The next, kind of, tip
that I want to highlight
is just, you know,
avoid trying to construct
the embed URL by hand.
We know
it's really easy to do.
You take the video IAD,
you prepare it
for youtube.com/v/.
Don't do that.
Instead,
use the media content URL
that we provide
in the feed response.
If you look at the URL
that we give you,
it actually contains
a lot more information
than what you
normally find.
I've noticed
the client ID,
a scrambled version
of your dev key,
and this is useful to us
and to you, too,
because if,
for some reason,
we suspect
there's any abuse going on,
if we can identify
the source of traffic,
we're much more likely
to go to you first
and figure out what's--
hey, you know,
what are you trying to do--
instead of just
shutting you guys down.
So having the ability
to know
what our developers
are doing is helpful.
And also we plan to make
all this information
available back to you
through a tool that
we are currently working on.
So if you use this way
of creating your embeds,
we can track
the number of playbacks
that are coming
out of your site,
which means we can
report this information
back to you
in our developer tool.
We're still working
on that tool.
It's not launched
right now.
It should be available
in a couple of months.
So the earlier
you start
providing
the right embed URL,
the more data
you're gonna have
when we do
launch that tool.
And just
a little tidbit:
instead of constructing
that whole HTML snippet by hand,
you know, consider using a
SWIFT object Java script library
that you can find on
code.google.com.
It makes it really easy
to create
these HTML snippets
for doing embeds.
If you're using
that Java script library,
you just need to set
the URL for that object
and, it will just
do the right thing for you.
Next thing
is versioning,
so, back in
October of last year,
not sure if all you guys
are aware,
but we-- that was when
we launched versioning.
So there's actually
two versions
of the YouTube APIs
in production today.
There's, uh,
V1 and V2.
V2 is the one
that we're actively supporting
and adding
new features to.
V1 is kind of frozen.
It doesn't have
as many cool features.
So if you want absolute
latest and greatest,
you should be
using V2.
If there's any problems
that we find in production,
we're much likely
to fix them for V2 first
than for V1.
Note that V2, however,
is not the default
in some cases.
If you are using
the raw HTML request,
You should add
v=2 to the URL request,
or add this additional
HTTP header field
to your headers.
And if you're using
a client library as you should,
in some cases
V2 is the default.
In some cases, not.
The best practice
is to always specify
which version
you want to use.
So, you know,
last but not least,
we just want to emphasize
that we at YouTube
really love
our developer community.
We work really hard
with our content providers
to make
as much content available
through the APIs
as possible.
This is not always easy
depending on
who we talk to
but we feel that
the developer community
is really
important to us.
We have a groups--
we have a group set up
at Google groups
that's very actively
monitored.
You know,
it's a great place
for you to post
your questions.
We try to answer as many
of the questions as possible.
A lot of the issues,
the problems,
the feature requests that
you raise in that group forum
get a lot of visibility
among the product team
and the engineering team
at YouTube.
So, you know, we take
your feedback very seriously.
So if you aren't already
participating in our group,
I highly, highly
encourage you guys to do so.
All right, that's
all I have
for you guys, today.
Are there any questions
I can answer?
Um, please
use the mic
if you have
any questions,
just so that we're--
we can capture that on video.
Anything?
Um, can you
use the mic, please?
man: Uh, hello.
Hey, um,
I was wondering if
you could maybe speak to
uh, why it is--could you help
explain what the--
what the caution is
regarding the ads
sold against videos?
And maybe,
I know you're not a lawyer,
but you can
help us sympathize
with why that's
not a good idea.
Yong: Um, so
the question was
can we perhaps
explain a little bit more
as to why we have
a clause that says
you can't run
an ad against a video.
And really
the main reason for that is
we need to be
absolutely sure
that you have the rights
to monetize that video playback
before we can
let you do it.
And in most cases,
if you're just
pulling videos from YouTube,
I mean, our agreement with users
who upload videos to us
is that it's really meant
to be performed
on YouTube,
and on other sites
if we do allow that.
And when that happens
the understanding is
the content provider
needs to be identified.
The rightful rights owner
of that video
needs to be identified,
and then
the rights owners decides
whether or not that video
can be monetized.
And if
monetization happens,
it needs to be
some kind of rev share,
or some kind of
a financial deal
with the original
content owner.
So if we're just letting you
put an ad next to the video,
you're really making money
from something
that doesn't
belong to you.
And we don't feel
that it's right.
I'm sorry,
you had a question?
man: I had
a similar question,
but on the other side
of the coin.
We're advertisers,
and we
actually wanted--
there's some videos
that are very useful for us,
and they get a lot of
page views,
video views
or whatever,
and they rank really high
on search engines,
and, on the
YouTube site.
And we'd love
to use adverts to
advertise
on those videos.
And we don't see any ads
over there.
We see comments;
we see the videos,
but we don't see
any ads.
If you could put in ads,
that would be great for us.
Yong: Oh, are you referring
to the watch page
or the
search results page.
man: I'm referring to the
YouTube watch page, or whatever.
Like, the--
Um, it shows up
on search result, like,
for one of the terms
that we are interested in,
for instance,
the YouTube video shows up
and it's really relevant
to what we sell.
So if you could put
an ad there,
that would be
great for us.
Yong: We do have different
ad products
if you want to advertise
on YouTube.
I mean, there is options
for targeting ads
on the watch page, as well as
on search results,
using AdWords
like systems,
so, I'm not sure
if you're aware
man: Oh, I was not
aware of that
because I don't see
any ads there,
so, I didn't know that
I could actually put ads--
Yong: Yes, so there is
a sponsored videos product,
which allows you
to promote videos
on search results pages,
and then separately there's
a way to buy advertising
on YouTube
watch pages.
So yeah, I mean, I can follow up
with you offline
if you're interested
in learning more
about the opportunities.
Any other questions
from you guys?
man: Hi.
Yong: Oh, sorry.
man: Yeah, I had
a quick question about the--
I've seen
some of the YouTube videos.
They have
some customization--
they'll have, like,
a red transparent bar
with some text on it.
Is that the
YouTube Pro version?
Yong: Um,
with different versions
of the embedded player,
and there's
the custom embedded player
where you can actually
customize the colors
around the chrome
of the video.
But there's also
the Chromeless player,
which is really
just a video canvas,
with no controls,
no UI,
just the video window,
and you can use Flash or
JavaScript or HTML, whatever,
to build a UI
around the player.
So some of the players
that you may have seen
were actually
created from scratch
on top of
a Chromeless player,
which is why the UI
may look a little different.
man: This was, actually--
the player was the same.
But on top of the video
there was some, uh, text
that was--that comes up
at a certain timeframe.
Yong: Oh, those
are annotations.
man: Annotations.
Yong: Annotations are actually
created by the content,
by the video,
by the person who uploaded
the video to YouTube.
And they basically
follow the player,
and you can actually
turn them off on the player--
man: Okay, how do I
create annotations?
Yong: Um,
annotations are actually--
create--there's no
API for annotations today.
So if you wanna create
annotations,
first of all you have to be
the owner of the video.
And you can do so
on the YouTube watch page
when you're logged in
as the owner.
And it's the
interactive graphical tool
for you to, to draw, like,
little speech bubbles--
man: So we don't need
YouTube Pro for that?
That's just
regular YouTube?
Yong: No, there's
no API at all.
It's a graphical tool
on youtube.com.
that you can use
to annotate videos--
man: And the name
of the graphical tool?
Yong: I'm sorry?
man: What's the name?
Is there like--
Yong: YouTube annotations.
man: YouTube annotations.
Yong: Yeah.
man: Okay, great.
Yong: And it's free.
man: [indistinct]
Yong: Course it's free.
man: Yeah, I gotta ask
a question
about the
Chromeless player.
We're actually
using the player.
The problem is you built
the player in Flash 2, right?
Yong: ActionScript 2.
man: ActionScript 2.
But we had to use
a local connection
or whatever way
to upgrade.
So my question is
what is your plan
to update
your versions?
Yong: We're aware of this.
We're working on it.
man: Yeah, it's kind of
frustrating because--
Yong: We understand,
and it's quite a
bad work around,
to get your--
man: So do you have
a plan at all?
Do you have a plan at all
for the future--
Yong: We're
working on it.
So, hang in there.
[laughs]
man: I have a question
that's more relate
to the little things,
but--
Today in YouTube
you can see more of the--
uh, copyrighted content
uploaded by somebody else.
Suppose if I'm writing
my own application,
and if
I'm searching, and, uh,
copyrighted content
if I display,
and the original owner
of that video,
if he flags it,
or if he sues me,
like, he's gonna fight it
whether it's me
or it's, uh, YouTube.
Yong: I'm sorry,
could you repeat the question?
So you own the video,
and someone else
uploads your stuff?
man: Yeah, there are,
like, three parties.
One is the owner
of the video.
And somebody else, actually,
they upload it.
They may capture it from
a television or somewhere.
They upload it
to the YouTube,
and then I search
in a YouTube--using YouTube
and it gets played
in my domain.
So the one
who is the owner--
he sees that video displayed
in my domain,
and he sues me.
So he's gonna fight it
whether it's me or it's YouTube.
Yong: Oh, they should
definitely come to YouTube
if they have a concern
about your content
because--because
we're just providing
the content to you
through the APIs.
Which is why it's important
for you to use
one of our embedded players,
because we provide
a channel
for delivering the video content
to the end user.
So if you run into
any issues like that,
please ask them to go to
youtube.com.
We have a site.
It talks about
our DMC obligations,
and what the escalation
process should be.
man: So that means I can do
any kind of search on there,
uh, YouTube,
and I can display the--
Yong: If you're, uh,
playing by the rules.
If you're adhering to
our terms of service, yes.
man:
Okay, thank you.
man: Yeah, I come very much
from the content creation world,
filmmakers,
Um, looking really at this
adding metadata,
and particularly
Adobe's plans with X and P,
the metadata
are all there.
Are there plans for that--
within the FLV file--
are there plans for any of that
within YouTube?
Yong: No,
I'm actually not aware
of what those specific
requirements are, so, no.
So, this is
additional metadata that--
man: Yeah, this is put in
at script stage
and it goes through
with the time code of the video
all the way through,
so it's,
then associated in
Premiere Pro in Adobe,
Premiere Pro
with the video.
So it's alongside
the FLV file.
It's gonna be a great way
to monetize the video.
Yong: It's not something
that I'm aware of,
but we can definitely
talk more,
you know,
after the presentation.
man: All right,
great, good.
Yong: Sure.
man: Can't I just extract
the audio--
Yong: Oh, I'm sorry, could you
move a little closer to the mic?
man: Can I extract
the audio portion of a video,
just insert it
in YouTube?
Like, let's say
that it's a song,
it's in video,
and I want to extract
the MP3 portion of it,
and then, is it legal?
Yong: See,
by doing that,
you're not using
authorized video players.
So automatically
the answer is no.
Because if you're using
one of our Flash players,
you can't
actually do that.
man: Uh, actually, like,
I saw that one of the plugins
[indstinct] on the internet,
they actually get the MP3 out
of--MP3 or MP4--
Yong: Yeah, I mean the--
We're aware of sites
that try to access
the video stream directly
and process that stream,
and we actually do block
those sites as we find them.
man: That's not legal,
actually.
Yong: Yeah, that's against
our terms of service, yes.
man: Thank you.
Yong: Cool.
Anything else?
If not, thank you so much
for your time.
Um, I'm actually gonna be around
for office hours tomorrow,
starting at 3:00.
I'm probably gonna be there
all day,
so, and we have office hours
tomorrow afternoon.
So I hope to see
some of you guys there.
We'll also have
a YouTube talk tomorrow
where we'll be announcing
a new social feature.
So, if you guys
wanna hear more
about what
we're announcing,
be sure to come
tomorrow.
And, again,
see some of you guys there.
Thank you.
[applause]